but today's bard shut is real price
volatility the new norm take a look at
this chart it shows oil price volatility
from 2007 to 2015 and right now
volatility is at the highest level since
April 2009 there it is at the right-hand
side of your screen now all prize of
volatility trough at 14.5 on june the
6th 2014 that's the red circle that's
when it reached a record low and data
going back to may two thousand and asset
and seven interestingly that low came
just 14 days before crude peaked last
year on june the 20th before embarking
on a sixty percent plunge through
january the 28th 2015 all investors are
being whipped sword on a daily basis on
wednesday wti crude slumped by
eight-point-five percent its biggest
drop since november as US crude
inventories expanded by 6.3 million
barrels to four hundred and thirteen
million barrels last week almost double
analysts estimates the highest level in
weekly records compiled since august
1982 rising us stockpiles of course
contributing to a go to a global glut
that pushed prices fifty percent lower
in 2040 I've been looking at the stats
in 2015 this year alone crude oil has
closed more than three percent lower on
eight occasions it's closed more than
three percent higher on five occasions
there's the volatility for you only
yesterday we were talking about oil
surging seven percent on Tuesday to
close at its highest level of the year
$53 and five cents a barrel that was
from a six-year low of 44 dollars 45
cents a barrel on January the 28th this
is the bottom line the bottom line is
this there's still an overriding concern
about supply that's according to
Jonathan Barrett he's CIO at areas
aligned securities in Sydney he says
it's all about finding a base and the
volatility we've seen shows it still
trying to
do that get ready for a new oil a new
normal for oil between seven sixty and
seventy dollars a barrel in the new in
the next few years those are the words
of Eurasia Group the new york-based
consultant is the oil price volatility
the new norm